[Music]
here in Windsor today I had the ultimate
royal run and I was just a few feet away
from the Queen of England and she looks
so happy
just sitting back watching her horses
and dark sunglasses and it's a jacket so
the Queen is directly behind me watching
some of her herd of horses compete I
know we're excited too in the raw
Windsor horse show here outside Windsor
Castle the Queen's 96 year old husband
Prince Philip dropped her off and was
spotted for the first time since we're
covering from his hip replacement
surgery
he's expected to walk unaided at his
grandson Harry's wedding the Queen is
passionate about horses this gorgeous
guy owned by the Queen is named
barbershop barbershop is an x-ray
schools went by the Queen Mother won
lots lots of races and all plus money I
heard that there's makeup and there's
hair extensions and this is like a real
glam squad - here has an extension in
his tail and he wears oil on his nose
and his eyes and all of his body's
making very shiny the royal forces also
participate in carriage races Prince
Phillip was actually one of the founders
of this sport and now here we are doing
it in his backyard I also got a personal
tour of the Royal cavalry stables these
beautiful animals performed at the show
and will be a part of Harry and Megan's
wedding I could imagine all the guys are
like I'm available it's the royal
wedding no big deal or is this just
another day in England for you the
husband and element have wanted to ride
on those once-in-a-lifetime parades
however any guy who gets asked to do it
will of course step up
[Music]